محمد شاهين اهلا بك في مساء العربيه
الهرشه السابعه شايف ايه اكتر رساله
قدرت توصل للناس بعد هذا المسلسل مش في
رساله معينه عايزين نوجهها على قد ما هي
الناس لو ما تشوفش بتتفرج على المسلسل
والاحداث اللي بتحصل فيه يمكن ده يعني هم
يطبقوه على حياتهم او حياه حد شافوه او حد
يعرفوه عاشوه معاه نفس الحقيقه دي يمكن ده
يغير حاجه يمكن ده يخليه يخليها الاثنين
متجوزين يخليهم يفكروا قبل ما ياخذوا قرار
اي قرار في حياتهم
فكره ان هو لما قلنا الاثنين دول لازم
يتكلموا مع بعض لازم لازم المشاكل دي
يخلصوها ما يبقاش فيه تراكمات ادم شفتوا
قبل كده اتحضرت له ازاي شفتوا في معارفك
في اللي حواليك طبعا
ادم شفته في كذا حد
وانا انا مش شبه ادم خالص ادم صبور بيعرف
يحتوي ويتحمل وكده انا ما اقدرش اعمل كده
لكن
[موسيقى]
التحدي بقى ان انا اعمل شخصيه عامله كده
يمكن انا عجبني قوي في ناس كانوا يعني
قالوا على المسلسل
على فيلم تسجيلي يعني
في كاميرا
حقيقي بجد يعني كلمني بقى عن كواليس العمل
ان كان كلها حوارات اسريه داخل بيت والله
كان جميل جدا
هادي ما فيش مشاكل يعني كثيره الممثلين
كلهم ناس مريحين جدا جدا امينه جمبري كثير
ما اشتغلتش معاها بس لما اشتغلنا حصل كليك
كده من اول مره
من اول مشهد يعني اللي هو دخلنا جدا من
جوا ادم قديم مره واحده
عملنا مثلا بروفتين ولا ثلاثه بس مع كريم
قبل ما ندخل
الجواز عندك الخلفه اكنك متجوزه عشان
تخليني بس
انت لغيتيني قالها هتدور اكتر على الاعمال
الاجتماعيه الخفيفه
الجديد
لو برضو مسلسل اجتماعي وكارت الحلو هعمله
ما عنديش مشاكل يعني شكرا يا محمد شكرا يا
نورتيني لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات